el corazón es un órgano muscular
encargado de bombear sangre que contiene
el oxígeno y los nutrientes que su
cuerpo necesita las secciones de bombeo
del corazón son
y la aurícula derecha
y el ventrículo derecho
a la aurícula izquierda y el ventrículo
izquierdo
en el corazón la sangre con poco oxígeno
fluye desde partes del cuerpo a través
de venas grandes hasta la aurícula
derecha luego la sangre se traslada a su
ventrículo derecho el cual se contrae
enviando la sangre fuera del corazón
para que reciba oxígeno de los pulmones
la sangre oxigenada sale de los pulmones
y se dirige hacia la aurícula izquierda
luego pasa al ventrículo izquierdo
finalmente el ventrículo izquierdo se
contrae enviando sangre oxigenada desde
el corazón hacia todo el cuerpo
si usted padece insuficiencia cardíaca
su corazón ha perdido la capacidad de
bombear suficiente sangre para
satisfacer las necesidades de su cuerpo
es posible que sus paredes ventriculares
estén débiles o dañadas y que no sean
capaces de bombear sangre suficiente
desde su corazón usted también puede
tener paredes ventriculares engrosadas y
rígidas que no permiten que su corazón
se llene de suficiente sangre
si tiene insuficiencia cardíaca del lado
izquierdo del corazón su ventrículo
izquierdo no envía suficiente sangre
oxigenada a su cuerpo haciéndole sentir
cansado y sin aliento
y la insuficiencia de su ventrículo
izquierdo también provoca un aumento de
la presión sanguínea en los vasos
sanguíneos ubicados entre los pulmones y
el ventrículo izquierdo
este aumento de presión hace que el
flujo salga de la sangre e ingrese a los
tejidos de los pulmones lo que dificulta
la respiración
si tiene insuficiencia cardíaca del lado
derecho del corazón su ventrículo
derecho no puede contraerse con
suficiente fuerza para impulsar la
sangre hacia los pulmones el resultado
es una acumulación de sangre en las
venas
lo que provoca una acumulación de
líquido denominada edema en todos los
tejidos del cuerpo
con el tiempo la insuficiencia cardíaca
a ambos lados del corazón resulta en el
debilitamiento y la hinchazón de los
ventrículos los cuales envían menos
cantidad de sangre al cuerpo
para compensar la disminución de la
cantidad de sangre el sistema nervioso
libera hormonas del estrés que
incrementan la velocidad y la fuerza de
los latidos del corazón lamentablemente
la liberación constante de estas
hormonas del estrés hace que su
insuficiencia cardíaca empeore porque
éstas dañan las células musculares de
los ventrículos la causa más común de
insuficiencia cardíaca es la cardiopatía
coronaria
y otras causas que dañan el corazón y
producen insuficiencia cardíaca son alta
presión sanguínea diabetes válvulas
cardíacas enfermas infectadas o dañadas
músculo cardíaco enfermo infectado o
dañado latidos del corazón irregulares
denominados arritmia defectos cardíacos
envenenamiento o abuso de sustancias
enfermedades pulmonares y problemas
respiratorios durante el sueño
denominados apnea del sueño
el tratamiento de la insuficiencia
cardíaca incluye medicamentos cambios en
el estilo de vida o en el caso de la
insuficiencia cardíaca extrema
dispositivos de asistencia para el ritmo
cardíaco o cirugía los medicamentos
diuréticos reducen la inflamación en el
cuerpo aumentando la cantidad de orina
producida por los riñones
y los inhibidores s/a son medicamentos
que permiten que los vasos sanguíneos se
expandan estos inhibidores ayudan a
disminuir la presión sanguínea y
previenen un mayor daño en el corazón
facilitando el bombeo de sangre
y los betabloqueadores son medicamentos
que bloquean los efectos de las hormonas
del estrés en el corazón aunque los beta
bloqueadores desaceleran los latidos del
corazón se utilizan principalmente para
proteger el músculo cardíaco contra el
daño a largo plazo causado por las
hormonas del estrés
es posible que tenga que hacer algunos
cambios a su estilo de vida como hacer
ejercicios de forma regular
y mantener un peso saludable
y dejar de fumar
y limitar el consumo de sal y de alcohol
y seguir una dieta saludable para el
corazón
y las cirugías para la insuficiencia
cardíaca avanzada incluyen cirugías de
bypass de la arteria coronaria para
mejorar el flujo de sangre hacia el
músculo cardíaco cirugía de
reconstrucción de las válvulas cardíacas
para mejorar el flujo de sangre a través
del corazón
y cirugía de reconstrucción del
ventrículo izquierdo para retirar el
músculo cardíaco dañado
y las cirugías para la insuficiencia
cardíaca extrema incluyen inserción de
un dispositivo para ayudar al corazón a
bombear sangre
y trasplante de corazón